we've gone over these facts many times  mr balboa the answer is still the same  can't you change the rules  under present federation rules  any fight between you and this russian  cannot nor will it be allowed  let's be realistic  the russian  he has not yet had one  legitimate professional fight  the bout he had with creed was a  publicity stunt  that backfired  what you guys are really saying is you  don't think i have a chance do you  come on what we're trying to say is why  temp fate let's find out more about this  man let's see what develops  he's had one professional fight and one  man is dead  but if it prevents another fatality it's  well worth it of course  best way to a boxing band  that's one more accident especially at  this this magnitude do you realize what  kind of magnitude this is  excuse me  you want to know what the bottom line is  you've got rules we've got rules  everybody's got to abide by those rules  you